TOLD CONFIDENCE IN RECENT DAYS
HE'S READY TO ACCEPT ANY OUTCOME
FROM THE PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: OH, THE DRAMA.
THANK YOU.
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON, BUT WHAT
HAVE WE LEARNED ABOUT JIM CALL
ME FROM HIS BOOK ON THE
INTERVIEWS HE'S DONE?
COMEY RAN THE MOST POWERFUL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN
AMERICA.
HE WAS A CENTRAL PLAYER IN THE
LAST PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION AND
THE AFTERMATH EVER SINCE.
YOU WOULD THINK HE WOULD BE
IMPRESSED WHEN HE SPEAKS, EVEN
IF YOU DON'T AGREE WITH HIM, BUT
NO.
JAMES COMEY IS AS CONVENTIONAL
AS THEY COME.
HIS INTERVIEWS AND SO MIKE TELLS
A DOING A Q&A WITH "US WEEKLY."
HE SAYS HIS LITERARY HERO IS
ATTICUS FINCH BECAUSE HE
COULDN'T THINK OF ANY FORMER
CLICHE THAN THAT.
HE SAYS HE WISHES TRUMP WOULD
READ "THE NEW YORK TIMES" OP-ED
PAGE.
HE SAYS HE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
SANDBERG TO A DINNER PARTY AND
SO ON AND ON.
THIS IS AMERICA'S TOP G-MAN OR
WAS?
HE SOUNDS LIKE EVERY OTHER SENSE
OF GUILT RIBBON LIBERAL.
NOT IMPRESSIVE AT ALL.
THAT'S WHY HE DIDN'T HESITATE
BEFORE DESTROYING ANY REMAINING
PUBLIC TRUST IN THE FBI IN ORDER
TO SELL THIS BOOK.
THE FBI DIRECTOR IS NOT SUPPOSED
TO LET EMOTIONS AND POLITICAL
CONSIDERATIONS INFLUENCE
INVESTIGATIONS, BUT COMEY
DOESN'T EVEN HIDE IT.
HE ADMITS HIS BEHAVIOR IN THE
FALL OF 2016 MAY HAVE BEEN
COLORED BY HIS DESIRE TO MAKE
HILLARY CLINTON A "LEGITIMATE
PRESENT."
THERE IS NOBODY AND EITHER
PARTY, REPUBLIC AND OUR DEMOCRAT
WHO WILL EVER AGAIN THINK THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION WAS
CONDUCTED FAIRLY.
WHEN THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION
FOR THAT MATTER.
HERE'S WHAT HE TOLD ABC ABOUT
THAT.
WATCH.
>> DID YOU TELL HIM THAT THE
DOSSIER HAD BEEN FINANCED BY HIS
POLITICAL AND OPPONENTS?
>> KNOWN.
I THINK I JUST TALKED ABOUT
ADDITIONAL MATERIAL.
>> DID HE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW
THAT QUESTION MEXICO THAT HE HAD
A RATE?
I DON'T THINK HE HAD
AN ANSWER TO THAT.
I DON'T THINK IT WAS MY GOAL TO
ALERT HIM THAT WE HAVE THIS
INFORMATION.
>> Tucker: TELLING THE TRUTH
WASN'T NECESSARY FOR MY GOAL.
APPARENTLY IT WASN'T.
WHATEVER ELSE YOU THINK ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP OR HIS
ADMINISTRATION OR WHATEVER, YOU
MIGHT BE HAPPY THAT THAT GUY,
JIM CALL      COMEY IS NO LONGER
JIM CALL      COMEY IS NO LONGEN
JIM CALL      COMEY IS NO LONGEI
JIM CALL      COMEY IS NO LONGEG
THE FBI.
DO THE THINGS THAT HE SAID LEFT